in Birmingham England wildlife cameraman
Steve donor is conducting a cutting-edge
science experiment don't do it mr. slug
you have so much to live for how are
they not getting cut to shreds this was
totally gross so why aren't these slugs
and snails getting cut to pieces get
ready folks
it's another clip where the answer is
mucus slugs these snails secrete this
mucus from glands on the underside of
their bodies this mucus is made up of
98% water and 2% carbohydrates and
proteins these are long-chain molecules
that form bonds to each other that allow
them to rotate break and reform allowing
the mucus to be stable but also flexible
slugs and snails can even produce
different types of mucus according to
their needs
there is thick mucus for example that
covers the entire slugs body or the
whole bottom of the snail to keep it
from drying out but they're thinner
mucus is more important for locomotion
or movement they use it when they want
to climb up walls when it's not under
pressure it's very sticky but when
there's stress applied to it such as
when the animal is wanting to move
forward it becomes much thinner and more
pliable and allows them to glide forward
so there's essentially a protective
layer between the bottom of the animal
and this very sharp blade no snails or
slugs were harmed in the making of this
video but they did get a close shave